[Musique]
règle générale dans notre système le
parti qui forment le gouvernement c'est
celui qui remporte le plus de cinq ans
cription chacune et donc portante et
tracer les frontières des ses
conceptions peut faire toutes les
différences parce que c'est possible
d'influencer le résultat le jour de
l'élection en incluant ou excluant
certains secteurs qui ont tendance à
bordés d'une certaine façon c'est
d'ailleurs de cette manière contre et
c'est la carte électorale dans les
premières années de la confédération le
parti au pouvoir définissez les contours
des circonscriptions de façon évidemment
à maximiser ses chances de faire élire
des candidats
c'est en 1903 qui est adopté une
première loin l'acte de la députation la
loi confie la tâche de dessiner la carte
électorale comité de députés de la
chambre des communes
mais comme le parti au pouvoir nommer
majorité de membres au sein de ce comité
le processus restait très tentée
politiquement il faut attendre jusqu'en
1964 pour que la loi sur la révision des
limites des circonscriptions électorales
viennent finalement mettre de l'ordre
depuis ce jour confie la définition des
frontières des circonscriptions à des
organismes non partisan tous les dix ans
du directeur général des élections
quel culot si le nombre total de sièges
aux communes ainsi que leur répartition
entre les provinces et des territoires
en suivant les données du recensement la
dernière modification de la carte
électorale canadienne a été faite après
le recensement de 2011 36 construction
ont ainsi été ajoutés lors de l'élection
de 2015 pour un total de 338 la
prochaine révision de la carte
viendra-t-elle recensement des 2021